Hmm, I have recently become interested in cooking, and I understand that you want to
improve your cooking skills for the sake of the younger generation, so I tried
serving some of my home-cooked meals to those close to me.
I
made the curry and rice exactly as I remembered it.
There is no way I have ever eaten curry and rice. It
is probably a dish from another world.
I won't ask you about it.It's called Surprise.This
green thing is
ore, isn't it?It's ore.Wow, when I saw the video of Young Master's memory, it
looked very delicious, so it's a
soft
emerald.It's a little green curry.
Probably the asparagus and the asparagus in
the pot are very
hot.It didn't turn out as
delicious as I expected, but I was in agony.Most of the food,
including the asparagus, didn't eat the ore,
or rather, I couldn't eat it.  Buildings and structures are
not food ingredients. Well, to you,
everything in this world is food food. Have you ever
studied cooking in the first place? You can handle fire
at least. Now, please brown this bread.
Emma is going to eat it.
How can you just serve it to me? It's not just roasting it over low heat. It's a very
evil-looking dish. How can you cook it? I have a
long way to go.